two listen guys
some people have been saying that we
wouldn't be back and frankly
they were almost right this time because
we haven't done a classic hd podcast
episode in
what feels like months so they thought
they had us
but they didn't my way back yeah yeah
we're back
and you know i'm glad to be back i've
missed this format we've been out
exploring we've been out and venturing
new formats
new ways of living but um
but we're back we like this one and
we've missed it
and i've missed you guys and i've missed
the crew i've missed talking to you guys
how are you guys let's start with uh
ian ian how are you feeling blessed
my man it's good to be back yeah
like an old friend you know all right
got a lot of catching up to do we do
have a lot of ca yeah i think we already
talked about thanksgiving and stuff but
we did
it's not like i haven't been talking to
you it's like we have been
yeah i want to i want to get some
feedback from you guys though a b
looking there i'll tap a b you're a
thr yeah the hd puck has heartthrob what
do you think about that
um i'm honored good lighting yeah
abby is married i am married good
lighting
although zach is the zach is the uh wild
card and he's
uh dating a porn star so we tip our
beanies to zach
a lot of people were really you know the
feedback when we unveiled that
zach was dating a porn star is that a
lot of people were
because apparently she's like a big porn
star she's like really
popular so people were like holy [ __ ] i
can't believe zach is dating
this porn star that is really popular
what what's her name again
jane wilde jane wilde ah yes
i'm trying to eat on camera get together
jane wilde we're a bad one the full
package
dan is doing good you guys all know dan
come on who's dan
today's episode is sponsored by tushy
and ridge
and uh should we do a quick teddy fresh
call out
news new drop new drop is live i'll do
this quickly
you know this is ela's baby so we owe it
to her
to showcase her fine work let me just do
this quickly we did it on frenemies
we got the ski jacket my favorite piece
okay the ski jacket
i just feel like we finally achieved
like a next level for me
with adding all the bells and whistles
all the details i've dreamed of
um the quality is there the fit is there
like it's all hitting the marks for me
i'm just really proud of this one yeah
it's a legit jacket you know yeah
i like it so we like that
congratulations you loaned the jacket
thank you we've got this we got this we
got the schmutz we got the bit
you get the drill head over to
teddyfresh.com and browse the new
collection
all right so um
man it's really like we never missed a
beat because here we are talking again
about jake paul which is our
headline story jake paul thinks covet is
a hoax
yeah what you know jake paul has time in
it time and again oh man
i hate talking about this guy but he he
is consistently surprising me and
and the internet at large but just what
a [ __ ] idiot he is
and it's like there's certain he's just
so stu
you just can't ignore him at certain
points like he won this big boxing match
i'm not dripping jake i mean you're
tripping telling people that kovit's a
hoax i mean that's crazy bro
at least he's stopped trying to pretend
like he's a role not really
yes you literally said it's a hoax i'll
prove it to you
so the the whole story we don't care
yeah well okay well finally you're being
honest
he says they don't care right
in an interview with the daily beast
jake paul claimed covet is a hoax
and 98 of news is fake okay
um the interviewer asked i love that
jake paul
thinks he knows better than all of
the scientists and epidemiologists
it's fake news bro all the people who go
to harvard
and do the whole thing you know what it
is smart people you know like the really
really smart people he knows better than
them
yeah of course well he jack unveiled
that he's magga country
that's fine well the thing is like
uh well there's difference between like
supporting being a trump voter which is
totally fine and then being like mega
country
i feel like there's a difference and
he's like mega country but the thing is
that he goes
so mega country is like covered as a
whole
i love it yeah yeehaw oh you liberals
over there in california with your fake
coven yeah he's stealing that
down here in kentucky with our welfare
state
we want we want to kick california out
of the republic
and they only pay like 30 percent of all
taxes yeah
who's going to pay for our med yeah i
love that kentucky goes
talk [ __ ] about all the liberal elites
but california literally pays for their
those [ __ ] medicare okay
anyway this is what the hd podcast is
baby we're back
so anyway he says i think the whole
uh covet thing is a hoax i don't really
think they believe it i honestly just
think they're that's their way of being
like
i want i'm selfish i'm gonna do what the
[ __ ] i want and i just wanna be able to
justify it in a way
that some people will at least identify
with and they'll even call me
based for it based
and then all of a sudden people like i
think they do believe it if they say it
they believe it
how there's like over 250 000 people
dead
that's fake like how like how can you
believe it
i just don't get it like at this point
everybody knows somebody who's been
affected by covet
you know so anyway the interviewer says
uh we do know that the health
professionals have said
but you're basically saying that you
don't trust what they're saying
and jake said um i don't think we do
know the health
i think we do know who the health
professional oh my god let me read this
again
jake says i don't think we do know who
the health professionals are
people like yourself or people who go on
twitter and read articles all day you
know
eighty percent of the news is fake 98
what is cut ethan let me drink another
cigar
swag of coffee sega coffee
[Music]
98 of news is fake so how do we know
what's
actually real and what we're actually
supposed to imagine how do you live your
life actually thinking that 98
of news is fake like how like imagine
how
paranoid and [ __ ] weird your
worldview like you have no
you have nothing to stand on you can't
anyone you can't call the new york times
fake and then watch like
newsmax sorry
i see people on twitter complaining and
being all upset
and saying this person knows this or
that but no one actually knows what to
believe
medical professionals have said that
masks do absolutely nothing to spread
those
to prevent the spread of covet bruh you
are [ __ ] dumb
you are like just dumb like bro have you
not read anything
bro you can't just say medical
professionals have said that mass do
absolutely nothing that's just
like that's just wrong that's just
tangibly false i mean that's just
provably false
right so what happened i i cause i
thought when we met him i still thought
there's some brain there
but i guess not i think he was trying
yeah
i think like logan's kind of ha ha on a
redemption arc
and jake's like i'm just gonna go like
uh
arch nemesis arc right but anyway
interview says they have not said that
in quite some time
yes they have yes they have you're
arrogant
you're very arrogant for saying they
haven't said that
what so and then okay so this guy puts
out the article
why arrogant so listen to this this is
even better
[Music]
jake the guy puts out the article and
then jake says
he was misquoted as saying kova 19 is a
hoax
he said he was lying about him that he
never said it was a hoax and that he
said it's very serious
so he so jake tweeted this out about the
interview he said
this reporter misquoted me he took what
i said out of context
and i told him that i told him that the
entire time
paul said covet is very very real covert
is very real
it's killed so many people it's called
people i know
it's killed some very very close to me
and that's what i'm saying i don't even
know where that came from so that's what
jake said
interesting but then the guy who
interviewed him yolo
yeah was like dude i recorded it i
recorded our interview
and he tweeted this out now you listen
to this and you tell me who's telling
the truth
oh no wow
there's audio
and i think i think the disease is a
hoax you think the disease is a hoax i
mean it's killed
about 260 000 people so far this year
[Music]
that's what i'm saying he's going to
tell me you got some tea today
oh yeah i got hot tea oh my god
what a [ __ ] dumb you want to listen
to this whole thing yeah it's a minute
30 but it's all good
yes can you imagine being that dumb
because i saw this stuff over the summer
and i gotta say it did
it did piss me off a little talking
about the covert party you were hosting
these giant
sort of masters parties at your home in
calabasas um
as covent cases were spiking in the
state
and you know it drew a number of
neighbor complaints and condemnation
from the mayor
and when insider asked you about it in
late july you said i personally
i'm not the type of person who's going
to sit around and not live my life i
mean i'm curious
do you do you regret those comments are
you still living by that mentality
yeah i mean it's time for us to open up
obviously it's a controversial subject
but it's time for our nation to open up
and uh go back to normals you really
think though
based on what yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't are unemployed right now
people are turning to alcohol and drugs
to
cope with you know he's like alcohol and
drugs
i'm doing that myself i'm super affected
by all this
[Music]
you think the disease is a hoax i mean
it's killed about 260 i mean
no in no unclear terms he specifically
states that it's a hoax
and that it's not more lethal than the
flu
which is like the talk you literally
said that jake it's on
audio you can't deny it he recorded the
conversation dude oh my god i just can't
believe this
you know who wrote the tweet that's like
someone else wrote it it's not even him
pr oh well i don't think jake i don't
think he knew that it was recorded
yeah no i know i think he was just like
ah fake news i could do anything i want
and then he's like right you're [ __ ]
idiot i have you on audio but you know
and then he's he's he's regurgitating
these talking points that like
people were saying you know six to eight
months ago
there's no deadlier than the flu all the
idiots who've been saying that had to do
like an apology
already jake's still saying it
how many people has the flu killed this
year 10 000 or something
you know what i mean look that up well
it's probably less
because of quarantine but that's an
unusual year
34 thousand thirty four thousand
that is mo well that's two thousand
eighteen thousand nineteen isn't it
that's the most recent flu so that's
fair so thirty four thousand verse
what now like what's it at like two
sixty that's something like that
yeah sounds like the same no bigger
threat
so apparently what does it feel like
like what are you experiencing right now
well i'm feeling embarrassment and shock
for you
thanks for asking um
kovid denying runs in the family ela as
you know
greg paul the dad is a fan or we're a
fan of his gp coming at you
gp coming at you you know and just to
remind you of who created
being a great role model so definitely
just remind you guys about who their dad
was he was started being in all their
videos and being their hype man and
manager
and he was actually living in an rv in
uh jake paul's driveway and i
and then he was doing like kissing games
with the girls in the videos and then
ultimately
a sex tape was released of jake of greg
paul had their dad
[ __ ] i can't i couldn't know the age
of the girl
allegedly allegedly yeah let's just
throw that oh i heard him being like oh
i mean okay yeah he
i could see his face eating out some
young girl's vagina bro
what's the legend about that you
couldn't see his face
there was a lot of there was a i mean gp
coming at you that's what he said when
he went down on her
that's what he says when he's ready to
go what's going on
people gp coming at you some not so
great behavior what's going on
okay well allegedly whatever yeah he
[ __ ] a young girl one of
one of the younger it was crazy the
guy's living a rv in the driveway and
he's [ __ ] all their friends like what
in the gods green earth
anyway here he is he's still at it on
instagram which is awesome
and he's super weird guy whoa
he always started in your look he always
starts his videos with this
and maybe it's for the thumbnail or
something but it's super weird let's
read it
you guys ready to get a uh
constitutional educat uh
constitutional uh uh update from the guy
who lives in an rv in his son's driveway
[ __ ] his friends
happy thanksgiving economic liberty
separation of powers freedom of
association
protest your governor interesting
let's go gp hit me with that yo folks
what's going on it's gp coming at you
hopefully some of you guys will look up
some of those things they talk about
economic liberty separation of powers
freedom of association
all those bro don't your kids need a dad
or something
[Laughter]
[ __ ] man don't worry about separation of
power just worry about [ __ ]
taking care of your son jake paul is on
a rapid
decline things
should be allowing us to keep our
businesses open
see our loved ones the government is
overstepping their boundaries i said
this before
this masked mandate is bigger than the
mask mandate now they're trying to come
into our house and tell us we can't
spend time with loved ones
and all this other [ __ ] everybody
should be
protesting their governor i don't care
if you're a republican or democrat get
together and protest your governors
because guess what
these mandates are hurting everybody
anyway i'm pushing back
and i say this i'd rather speak up and
be wrong than be muffled
and be wrong i'll say it again i'd
rather speak up and be wrong
then be muffled and be wrong okay so so
they're starting to like
internalize that they might be wrong
yeah it's happening
that is happening i was vocal yeah
but the ultimate irony is that nobody's
stopping you from talking and nobody's
stopping you from having thanksgiving
dinner
yeah that's the thing look you you were
vocal and you may have killed a grandma
too
sure that's the thing about all these
guys who made like thanksgiving dinner
with their family a point of like
they won't take our turkey kobe might
take our lives but they won't take our
turkeys
yeah um nobody tried to stop
thanksgiving dinner they just said
please don't do it because it's
dangerous
and they're like [ __ ] you you can't stop
me they're like we're not trying to stop
you we're just saying that it would be
good for society as a whole if you could
think as
instead of like selfishly on the
collective and maybe just skip
thanksgiving for a year
i'm bringing my ak and all my ghosts
i'm bringing all my weapons this
thanksgiving the kids
the fascists show up
[Applause]
i love the the quick lick line and like
the video
it starts with like look it up
separation of powers
i'm so educated right 30 minutes 30
seconds
later is like look i might be wrong but
[Laughter]
that's a great quote
nobody's trying to stop you from any of
these things people are just asking you
please for the love of our your country
your own family you want them to get
sick go ahead
i got family coming from all 50 states
no masks
no masks rule whoa
jake said in that tweet that someone
very close to him died from covet
yeah he didn't say that apparently yeah
well he didn't care about them that much
clearly he's like covert actually has
been great
the only person that's died from is the
uncle that i don't like at all so it's
been
net positive for me yeah
covered ain't real i vote in donald
trump
because covert ain't real
yeah anyway so this segues into our next
story
i believe that separation of church and
state
is all what that matters and if and i
might be wrong but at least i was vocal
yay
that's the best one ever can you sound
bite that zack
i need that in my life more
so jake paul won this boxing match
and then he threw a massive party to
celebrate winning the fight
with like hundreds of people no masks
yadda yadda let's take a look i think he
did it on the day
the day and all right yeah it was it was
monday evening which was the day that
california put in their
uh safe at home yeah at home yeah
so here's what it looks like and shout
out to banks and all these responsible
people
i i don't know if that's him it's just
his banks here i don't know if it's him
or not but
uh probably the thing is like can you
just not be selfish for one [ __ ] year
like you don't have to go to a party you
know i understand there's some things
you need
selfish and google separation of power i
go
google separation of power
i might be wrong about this muffled that
is phase banks by the way
okay yeah [ __ ] you dude you're a big
piece of [ __ ]
i mean really i mean hey look what he
says this is good fun
this is good fun right
i mean like can we and especially now
it's so
bad right now it's like the the solution
is right around the corner we're gonna
be having vaccines next year
you know this is not an essential
activity you selfish [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] essential but it's good
fun
yeah it is good fun it does say this is
good
you do offer an interesting counter
point you though
can you guys at least wear masks like
what the [ __ ] bro
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh cardi b's there cardi b's at the
party
oh [ __ ] you guys listen to car tv
dude there's nothing safer than like
hundreds of people's packed into a tight
league
tightly wound room all screaming
masculus
oh god you know this is a super spreader
event there's literally
denials too like you know they're not
safe this is there's no way this isn't a
super spreading event
oh my god oh my god
oh my god gp
gp coming at you he's right there
it's a proud dad yeah i mean name them
and shame
you guys name them and shame them spot
them and shame them dude
as a [ __ ] dummy is obvious that's
like saying the sky is [ __ ]
blue
[Applause]
there's logan [ __ ] idiot the mom too
wait logan's such a [ __ ] hypocrite he
acts so woke on his podcast about kovit
and all
he is breathing covered air like this is
aerosol
covered air bro if you could bottle this
air and spray it in someone's face
you would give that would be a
biological attack i wonder
like all the people that go on his
podcast does he make a claim and like
hey i'm a cover denier
comment you're learning i mean i don't
know why anyone sits across the room
because
[ __ ] dude you're like what the [ __ ]
dude i don't really give a [ __ ] but
thanks for letting me know right yeah
i think jake paul or logan paul is
trying so hard to rebrand himself but
like
let's be honest he's still this [ __ ]
douchebag
sorry i'm a little upset
and you know what [ __ ] it dude
somebody's gotta
just just [ __ ] watch from home i know
it's a big deal and your brother's
fighting and what do you just [ __ ] you
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled and be wrong
nobody's muffling you greg paul you [ __ ]
by the very fact that you put that video
on
instagram nobody's muffling you like
by the very definition of the video that
you're posting
right nobody's muffled you what greg
gp's up
okay uh yeah maybe stay out they'll be
checking out for
for permanently after this party
at his age
damon sheamon who else is here at this
dumb [ __ ] party it's a bunch of people i
don't know them
but a lot of them are
influencers
[Applause]
i know who that guy is i liked him but
not good i don't i don't know his name
but he makes funny videos but
i don't like it dude
[Applause]
he blew it
okay and then the third time he went to
sleep
his mom is there god damn you guys are
stop
i was like dude we're in a panda like a
literally a pan
like a hundred year pandemic
is he talking with a young girl hold on
let me back it up
[Applause]
and i've been in front of the whole
family yeah i think they're like goofing
on them a little bit like greg's up to
his old [ __ ] rapey ways y'all uh-huh
gp coming at you
[Music]
all right
you get the idea yeah and then you know
you notice the phone call you get like a
week later
zack you know the phone call you got a
week later
what was the name of that guy who called
jake and logan
he got it from hanging out with them
mm-hmm
enter fox i believe yeah hey bro um
so i have some i have some bad news
oh man that's tanner calling jake to
tell me he has coveted after hanging out
with him
what what did shake say
uh so i have some i have some bad news
uh-huh we got that part
you're tripping all right
oh you know what i gotta say obviously
i'm very critical of tana
but keemstar made this one tweet about
this whole situation that left my
head spinning oh really so i thought it
was
worth mentioning just because keemstar
we were already spinning
no but wait to wait till your head spins
even more okay
so so tana four months ago
black lives matter can and now ha ha my
friend knocked out this black guy
all she said was laughed my ass off this
age poorly
he tweeted nap time she said lol this
age poorly and then keemstar made it a
racial issue
like what the f like what like what jews
tana black lives matter now ha ha my
friend knocked out this black guy
where did they race it i mean i like
he's accused like he's bringing a breaks
where it's not there at all it's not
there yet it's like it's not their way
at all
you're a weirdo all jews all jews
keemstar i know that you don't like
black people as
far as i can tell but how do you feel
about jews
he's thinking all jews go ahead you can
do it zach i give you permission
tell show the people what keemstar
thinks about jews death to all jews i
knew it
i knew it
not surprised keemstar later deleted his
tweet after everyone was goofing on
[Laughter]
good luck ethan because you're gonna
[ __ ] need it
all right it's break time y'all when
when we come here you really cross the
line
all right calm down you're the one
that's all jews i'm just sitting here
doing a show
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite okay fine
just shut up dude i'm trying to do a
show
[ __ ] dumbass so annoying garbage
okay all right we're going to do a quick
break
we have a ton of good stuff to talk to
when we get back we got the monolith
story we got
there's this guy dr mike who also was
like
there's like a whole playlist on his
youtube channel about like kovid
and oh god calling people out and being
like a high and mighty coveted
person like me i'm a high mighty call
every person
okay it's not a denier no he's not a
denier but then he went out and partied
without max
with all these people and he got and he
had to go on an apology tour so we're
going to slam on dr mike
among a lot of other fun stuff so don't
go anywhere
you poop you wash you dry
it's a three-step process and it's the
magic of tushy
until she's in the business of blasting
ass
with water listen everybody's got an ass
and everybody deserves the gift of tushy
during this holiday trust me it's one of
the best gifts you can give someone the
magic
of the bidet i'm a man that went from
wiping
to baby wipes and i feel i feel like i'm
the embodiment of that meme where it's
like enlightened
super enlightened ultimate enlightenment
you know and the bidets at the top and i
gotta tell you
it's changed my life wiping your ass
is gross you're literally putting your
hands in your ass and how many times
your finger break through
you get [ __ ] under the nail it's not
pretty but it happens let's be honest
folks
the bidet fixes that it blasts your
butthole
with clean uh
what i mean it's like a power wash on
your [ __ ]
what more do you want than that it's a
power wash for your [ __ ]
you know also toilet paper especially
baby wipes horrible for the environment
i learned
it's easy dude here's how it works
um tushy has an attachment it clips onto
your existing toilet and sprays your
butt completely clean with fresh water
it's called tushy and it's the best
thing you could do for your butt
tushy sprays directly to your ass and
removes the poop completely so you
aren't sitting on bacteria that leads to
nasty things like hemorrhoids yeast
infections ut eyes
itchy buttholes and skid marks the days
are common in the rest of the world so
catch up americans it's time to get
water squirting at your [ __ ] and
leave toilet paper behind in the past
where it belongs
the bidet also saves you money on toilet
paper because let's be honest that
shit's expensive
i've had debates about this on this
podcast and it is expensive
dollar per roll [ __ ] that
[Applause]
won't clog your toilet come on
you know what time it is it's only 79
bucks apparently according to this copy
wet wipes are can cause anal fissures
bruh
i'll do anything to prevent an anal
fissure stop
i don't like the sound of that isn't
that when your [ __ ] like prolapses
no i think it's like a cut yeah it's a
cut on your [ __ ]
yeah you don't want it i don't whatever
it is i don't like it yeah we don't
fissure with with uh
you know the tushy look it's an
attachment
you're gonna end using toilet paper
forever this is only 79 bucks it's
ridiculous we love
toshi you could also get the tushy
ottoman it helps you get everything out
you put your feet up it's like a sexy
cloud that helps you poop and it's only
an additional 69 bucks
not bad but the tushy itself is only 79
bucks
if you go to hellotushi.com h3h3
you're going to get 20 off of your order
and free shipping
but only until december 6 we better get
on that
right now at hellotushy.com
h3h3
all right you know what time it is it's
ridge wallet time
there's nothing better in this world
than this fresh ridge wallet that's
going to change the game because let's
face it you're probably using an old
school wallet
that's got bells and whistles and
buttons and zippers and all this crap
and it's probably huge and it weighs a
lot it takes a lot of space in your
pocket or your bag or however you carry
it around
this is just ancient technology it's
time to throw that away with the bass
with the 20 20 year let's throw it all
away
ridge sleek futuristic
dependable here's how it works you could
fit up to 14 cards inside this slot here
put them in there easy to use
aerodynamic design
push this button they pop out they pop
in bada boom and
a paperclip on the back this thing is
indestructible you can buy this and have
it
for life uh that's the bridge guarantee
look at all these cool designs they've
got
carbon fiber forged carbon damascus is
sick i'm not gonna hate dude
damascus is kind of the dopest one on
the site right now
but look at all these cool ones you know
tons of uh options um
let me tell you let me tell you
there's thirty thousand five star
reviews
come on what more do i need to say than
that it has a lifetime warranty you
could buy this
and own it forever a lifetime warranty
they're so confident you're gonna like
it
they'll let you use it for 45 days and
if you don't love it you can send it
back for a full refund
that's confidence you know
so that's pretty much all i have to say
about that it's kind of as good as it
gets what do you think about your ridge
wallet ab
so you've got it ready love it do you
easy simple it's my jeans doesn't bother
me
do you love it you wouldn't just say
that would you no i bought this before i
even worked for you believe it or not
you did using the h3 discount wow
now i'm really happy i heard you
but you don't regret it no i don't no i
still use it did you have a big old
ancient
uh wallet before actually i had a
slimmer wallet but it was still not as
convenient as this one nothing slimmer
than this let's face it yeah
yeah nothing as long as nothing
that's what we love get 10 off today
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to ridge.com
h3 that's ridge.com h3 and use the code
h3 get 10 off
free shipping there's a link in the
description
we love you
we're back we are back
coved is still
real yeah i mean it depends who you're
asking
the paul family gp coming at you
that's what he says when he goes down on
a young girl
i already made that joke gp coming at
you allegedly
um yeah allegedly apparently
dr mike who
i've never heard of dr mike but
apparently he's like a hot doctor
that's what he's known as his instagram
account went viral after he featured
he was featured in buzzfeed in people's
magazine 2015 as the sexiest doctor
alive
i mean look i'm not he's definitely
handsome i mean don't get me wrong but
i'm not sure that i'm ready to call him
the handsome
the sexiest doctor alive are you he
looks kind of
like not there yet with you dr mike
don't you agree i mean you could be
honest with me
i just is he really a doctor that's yeah
he's a doctor he is really a doctor
a parent he says he's bored my doctor
has time for a youtube channel do you
think that he's not the you think he is
the sexiest doctor alive
i wouldn't go and say the sexiest but
you would
but you are into doctor mike i'm not but
because you're not denying it
i'm i mean i'm not going to deny that
that turns me off fine you know it's
fit obviously you you mean fine like ooh
he's fine or like
handsome he's not i have no
feelings if you're going there you're
trying to go there cause usually when i
set you up and i go
look at this guy he says he's the
sexiest you go yeah [ __ ] this guy but
it's usually not giving me that
you want to [ __ ] doctor mike i don't
vin diesel is interested even vin diesel
do you think dr mike is the sexiest man
uh sexiest doctor alive
am i right or wrong i ask you i don't
understand that response
anyway here's his youtube channel
um where he's made a ton of videos
in fact his top playlist if you look is
about covet
coronavirus truth that's his featured
playlist with a shitload of videos lots
of views too look at all these videos
that's what i'm saying what kind of
doctor has time for youtube
i don't think he's pro he's probably not
practicing he's probably just a social
media
guy hey everyone welcome to forward we
are a new kind of doctor's office
these people have been running ads like
maybe we'd be just better off
we gave it to everybody so let's see
what kind of videos
oh my god there is so much
misinformation going on with this novel
corona
boggles my mind and it's causing people
to panic make bad decisions
my patients are confused so i decided to
make this video
and take on misinformation by watching
some clips reading some articles with
you
so anyway he's there he's there to tell
you the truth the real truth
the problem is dr mike while he's
telling people to stay at home and be
careful
he's out partying masculus on a boat
according to the new york post
who [ __ ] who [ __ ] got him by the way
new york post got his ass
[ __ ] don't get on the wrong side of
those [ __ ] who was the people
that got gavin like those these people
are
they're ready man they're like [ __ ]
ready for you my ass they better not
catch my ass slipping because i am high
and mighty as [ __ ] on kovid
they're gonna catch me like peeping
something
what would they catch me doing you
actually don't do anything
thank you i don't leave the house
[ __ ] nice try
there they go they're like who are you
so here he is parting on a boat yeah
that's that is not safe behavior right
that is like the opposite of safe
behavior the images have sparked outcry
bro and like they were posted to
somebody's instagram so you
you literally posed for a picture like
dude what
yeah dumb [ __ ]
oh my god this is the t yes
the images have sparked an outcry on
social media because dr mike has spent
months preaching the importance of
mass and social distancing fatigue
because now we're going to be spending
more time indoors because of the weather
we need to play it safer than we have
over the last two
three months play it more conservative i
agree take less
chances i agree be around less people at
least for the next six
to eight weeks what about a
party on a boat why are you in a boat
with some fine ass
tail okay so now i don't i don't need
why exactly do i need to see random
[ __ ] tweets for some
dumbass people it's sheena twitter was
mad
like like you know what i mean come on
guys
and clearly these aren't even real
tweets like look at the font like
what's with the tweets i mean maybe they
just redid it
yeah well come on better yeah well [ __ ]
them fake news
maybe you can learn actually that's a
good idea
yeah well talk to talk to the team about
that what does jason menard have to say
about this let's see
well we have a yeah uh a rep for doc oh
he has got a rap
geez bro you are like
his rep said all federal state and local
cdc guidelines related covert travel and
safety we're followed oh
[ __ ] you are a [ __ ] you just got owned
being a [ __ ] about it dr mike hypocrite
i don't like these hypocrites like gavin
newsom it's like you you
you go you everybody who listens to you
all the good work you've done is now
undermined
you know it's like when they uh it's
kind of like when they find out
you've got a corrupt detective who faked
evidence in one case and then they got
to throw out like
hundreds of cases he's done before all
the work you've done
so you're a [ __ ] hypocrite you're
basically equivalent to a cop that
sprinkles crack
on a crime scene bruh
so he actually made a video apologizing
he said which is kind of funny because
he posted it to his alternate channel
oh that has like very small subs
which is kind of epic so i thought what
was the story with that he posted on a
small channel with like 50 000 followers
his main one has like over six million
yeah his main uh yeah his main has over
six and his smaller one i believe is
around 50k
but but he they couldn't escape because
youtube trended his video
oh he's awesome so here's dr mike
admitting when i'm wrong
for me this risk level was okay
but even considering all that what does
that mean what about that was okay you
literally grouped with like 10 people
like
mouth to mouth it's not okay
yeah you go elo was okay
but even considering all that even
considering following the rules
as the guidelines that are set forth it
doesn't matter
i messed up i really did
and i need to do better the reason i'm
saying this
is because of the impact of my trip
the impact can harm
the medical message that i've been
delivering from the beginning of this
pandemic
that covet 19 is serious that masks are
benign yet
jake do you hear this important measure
to reduce the spread of covet 19
and that i take it very very seriously
when i go to work i wear a mask
and i walk there i wear a mask when i
exercise in the gym
i wear a mask but when i'm invited
what's killing me most right now is like
people leave negative comments and
i deserve that i'm accepting of that i
messed up here it's
true but when i see bad actors
and conspiracy theorists try and use my
situation yep that's what you get now
that's what you did
that's what you enabled you see dr
mike you know you're tripping that's
what that's what people are selling you
you [ __ ] literally enabled
jake paul to attack
the legitimacy of covet 19 to downplay
its risks to say masks don't work yeah
but
you know whatever [ __ ] you dead to me dr
mike
alive and dead to me within the span of
20 minutes
here's the original video uh that
that youtube trended let's see
isn't that awesome it's got a million
views he tried to hide it on his little
channel and youtube's like nah [ __ ] this
guy
here's the top comment i'm getting tired
of people in power saying stay at home
and not doing it themselves
me too dude you're right as someone who
stays at home you're right
you're more sorry you got caught
apologizing is good but you're a massive
hypocrite
i didn't like his apology it wasn't good
enough i was
even though i was following all the
rules and technically i didn't
technically it was okay for me what does
that mean you shouldn't even say that
yeah but did you guys see how hot he
looked right so basically what he's
saying
i'm good looking so i can i get a little
passes here and there sometimes
you tell me what about this is following
the cdc guidelines
um there is just no guidelines
specifically to
people a boat party with a bunch of hot
girls in bikinis
so if they specified that exactly then
he would have followed but
they didn't they weren't specific enough
yeah
here's some photos apparently but this
is the best one yeah
it's so good vin diesel any thoughts on
this photo
what is he up to man there's like three
guys
i never been to a party like that well
you're not the hottest doctor
but like damn what is this guy getting
up to on his weekends [ __ ]
three dudes oh there's a fourth guy back
but he's not getting any clearly
he's like hey [ __ ] this guy
dr mike how you doing
did you uh did you hear about the part
where um
what do you call it uh he he threw his
friends under the bus
and kind of blamed them no no tell me
about that well because the boat party
was
was uh a present that they got for him
and he basically made it out to be like
i couldn't be rude and turn down a gift
yeah
that's even dumber i forgive him
he blew it who's the bigger hypocrite
doctor mike or gavin newsom
doctor mike big time i don't know gavin
newsom's literally ordering like
60 million people to stay at home
i feel like well maybe i'm wrong but i
just don't like dr mike
gavin newsom this guy just has a youtube
channel gavin newsom's the [ __ ]
governor bro
i just get the feeling that dr mike is a
douche and gavin newsome probably did
make an honest mistake i don't know i
shouldn't they both suck
i'm more mad like a douche i'm more i'm
more mad at gavin personally
because he's a governor he's the [ __ ]
governor you're right
i'm wrong and also that situation they
were in tight
was was actually probably even worse
than his because it was indoors
eating dinner well i'm sure they were
indoors too right
but all the photos were outdoors yeah
but the boat has an indoor yeah he was
[ __ ] indoors
yeah yeah and you know he [ __ ]
you know dr mike fox yeah you know he
[ __ ]
i know dr mike gets a lot of [ __ ] about
not having experience
for the stuff he talks about so this is
really bad for him because a lot of the
topics a lot of like people in the
medical community at least in my
experience they're always talking about
how he speaks on things that he doesn't
have the experience to be speaking on
because he's not a specialist he's like
a general practitioner and he's like
yeah ryan he's such a new doctor when he
became famous maybe now he'll have
experience with kobe to talk about it
the truth is yeah i mean if you come in
straight out of medical school
these people these doctors that
specialize like his knowledge of
of certain like special specialties are
probably not much more than a
normal layman right like me for example
listen to me i'm dr mike i'd rather
trust you than dr mike
thank you zach that's what i'm going to
get at who was right about covet all
along
dr dan you me all right dr dick
i put my neck out there yeah
i put my neck out there
come on yeah the ding
the ding knows what time is it do we oh
we don't have case
the new cases are about to go crazy just
stay in so
just stay inside just protect yourself
that's all i can say
and your family your friends you know
really i just go good doctor mike
specializes in
family medicine yeah that's general
that's that's like very general
say hey my throat hurts
family doctors they literally just refer
you to specialists yeah
here's a note for work for two days and
yeah go see a special
i like family doctors don't get me wrong
but like if you have anything
complicated be like ah here's a [ __ ]
referral here's a referral
what are you kidding that's like all
they do
oop all right you guys want to talk
about the monolith or you want to talk
about the
i have more covered news actually
no but it's so funny addison ray addison
ray
tick-tock star shut down
a major covet testing site in la so she
could shoot her dumb
[ __ ] movie called he's all that
he's all that shuts down major testing
site in los angeles
and then the mayor apparently was
unaware and he quickly when he heard
about it
how the [ __ ] does miramax close down a
testing site and the mayor doesn't know
film studio miramax previously granted a
permit to film at the union station on
tuesday cancelling any appointment made
by la residents to get tested for
governor there
oh that's like like hmm madison ray he's
all that
tested thousands of people i can't
believe they funded that script jesus
yeah bro that's going like straight to
i can't even imagine what's what's a bad
enough network for that
uh hallmark yeah youtube reds
so this is like a you said miramax or
something yeah
okay so this is a big so it's not really
addison ray's
yeah no she's in of course of course she
right right yeah okay because i saw this
earlier too i
misunderstood that it was like for like
a tick-tock shoot or something but
like a real movie i think what's funny
is just how unimportant it is
it's a addison ray he's all that movie
shutting down you know it's [ __ ]
great
so the mayor the mayor says
yeah the mayor's office reportedly
unaware
a rep for miramax told page six this was
not a request for miramax and once they
learned of the disruption production
acid the testing company resume its
service
apparently it was nobody's fault and and
you know nobody knew anything about it
miramax was like hey it's not our fault
the mayor's like i didn't know
meanwhile addison's ray's like listen
he's all that
[Laughter]
youtube premium i guess it would be the
film office ultimately that
they have granted the permit like they
would have had
but the city however some [ __ ]
guidelines in terms of like
what do you think so well and i guess
they did because they overruled it right
like they
well they shut it down and then the
mayor heard about it and it was like nah
because it turned into a story i saw
people tweeting about it right yeah i
guess if people didn't get up in arms
it probably would have still happened
all right let's talk about something
other than calvin then we can get back
with coven
so you guys heard all about the monolith
it's pretty interesting
so the story is that um
people from the utah department of
public safety were flying
overhead and they saw this weird
structure in the middle of like a very
remote part of the desert
and they came back and they took this
footage here
mysterious monolith pretty big
pretty pretty gnarly i mean this is
straight up a scene at a star trek other
like wandering down the rock side
yeah straight out of uh 2001 space
odyssey too
there was goats brothers goats oh [ __ ]
what does it mean
pretty interesting though yeah really
captivating
three meters high so what is that like
10 feet or something
that's pretty big planted firmly in the
ground
yeah now what really interests me about
this
yeah it's totally a reference to that
it's literally identical
so what really interests me about this
is that
people on the internet using like google
satellite imagery
went back at that exact location and
then they could tell how long it's been
there
and apparently it's been there since
2016. it's been there for four years
before somebody discovered it
really yeah oh i didn't know that i
thought it just showed up
it was there yeah i mean they just found
it but it was there for four years
wow pretty impressive yeah it's kind of
just
spooky even it's kind of incredible how
like in this in this country there's
places that are so remote you can put
something
like that for four years and it's not
discovered
so here's some more pictures of it so it
was in such a good shape after four
years
i agree man they made that thing to last
for sure
also the place they found to put it is
like so badass
yeah it's like a perfect set
you know so anyway
now it's at an undisclosed location
because
authorities didn't want curious seekers
becoming stranded
and need to be rescued but of course
people found the location almost
immediately
yeah um
david suber may have been among the very
first to view the monolith in person
coordinates were circulated around
reddit
here's the video that he posted when he
found it
this was this was actually one of the
more interesting videos because
he answers a lot of questions i had
about it he like knocks on it he says
whatever
the magnet test i don't know how to full
screen damn you can't zoom in
i can do like you can do like this
how's that look dan so i didn't bring a
strong enough one but
not sticking not magnetic okay those are
the attempts
and probably aluminum then let's see so
is it solid
not solid it sounds a little bit like a
cardboard box
super hollow
you got rivets and hand prints from
probably from diesel dave
going all the way up and then it's three
different panels
you can see there so all the panels are
separate and then riveted
hollow riveted not magnetic
hey very interesting
right so
the theory that's really interesting is
there's an artist called john
mccracken who is known for making kind
of art that looks exactly
like that oh really here's an example of
his art he was obsessed with sci-fi
and minimalist art stuff like this
here's a piece of his art on the right
for comparison now there's no
actual evidence to say that this is his
work and he
has passed away
some time ago actually
but people think it's a bona fide piece
of his art one problem of course is that
no nobody who knows him thinks it was
his
knows anything about it his friends his
dealers yeah
his son though had a really interesting
anecdote who's still completely puzzled
by he said
when he heard the news he immediately
thought of an evening when
in 2002 when his father said to him
um that
he said something to the fact of that he
would love to leave his artwork in
remote places to be discovered later
he was an avid reader of science fiction
he believed in time travel
and extraterrestrial life
so basically
nobody knows really where it came from
but the the best theory so far is that
it's somehow related to this guy
although again nobody knows and he
passed away
but it has been there since 2016
according to satellite imaging his name
is john mccracken
here it is by the way here here's the
earliest known satellite image from
2016.
wow that's crazy yeah because it says on
google that
john mccracken died in 2011
which would have been five years before
yeah yeah first showed up on
yes that's correct huh that's correct
so they're theorizing that he uh had
instructions to somebody
to uh to carry out this thing after his
passion that's the mystery right
so yeah he passed away before this thing
was erected
by some five years or something like
that
but the construction is definitely like
made by somebody who knows what they're
doing
yeah it's really impressive the fact
that it lasted so long
and the way that it's anchored into the
ground firmly that's not easy
yeah it's installed really clean
definitely a professional
so um
now the annoying part it disappeared
yeah
and everyone thought like you know
it's part of the the art exhibit but
this leaked out i saw a video here
on tick tock actually this morning and
it looks like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
actually just
just took it just removed it of course
right yeah
let's see we all wondering what happened
to the monolith because my buddy was
there and he got it on film so my buddy
and his friends went out to the monolith
around
four o'clock p.m and one of the things
that they mentioned is well he's a
photographer and one of the things that
they mentioned is he wanted to get there
because it was also a full moon that
night and this is what he said
i just finished taking some photos of
the monolith underneath the moonlight
and was taking a break thinking about my
settings i needed to change for my last
battery of drone flight
when we heard some voices coming up on
the canyon we were contemplating packing
up our things as they walked up
so they could enjoy it for themselves
just like we did at this
point i looked down at my watch and it
was 8 40 p.m
four guys rounded the corner and two of
them walked forward they gave a couple
of pushes to the monolith and one of
them said
you better have got your pictures he
then gave it a big push and it went over
leading to one side he yelled back to
his other friends that they didn't need
the tools
the other guy with him at the monolith
and said this is why you don't leave
trash in the desert and this is the
second part you could pause it
because i don't want to have a part two
this is the photo of the guys pushing
the monolith i missed the chance at
first i was like man is that really true
but then this morning i saw there's a
new york times article
saying the same exact thing that um
do you guys have the new york times
article in here
well anyway it's it's the same info he
says
this is why you don't leave trash in the
desert trash
suggesting that the monolith is an
eyesore and a pollutant to the landscape
he did not photograph the man because he
didn't want to start a confrontation
really
apparently this someone got a few
photographs of him here let me open this
new york times article but it's like
what's you're such a [ __ ] douche you
know yeah [ __ ] you dude
you're a piece of trash so here they are
removing it they said leave no trace
the article of course is the burners
is earthlings it seems that not aliens
removed
the utah monolith
why would you do that it's just like
such an [ __ ]
they're like let's go out there and
throw it out
there's a lot of people that uh feel
that
you know you're like disrupting the
environment by uh
going out into these remote places and
it was there for four years
yeah yeah the fact they said leave
like if they actually said leave no
trace or whatever that's the whole
burning man philosophy or whatever
you know how they have the party in the
desert every year
yeah that's like their motto is leave no
trace yeah i'm sure they leave no trace
i'm sure
so another monolith appeared in romania
days after the that one disappeared
but it's probably just a copycat there
you have it guys the monolith story
i don't know what do you think about the
guys that went in there removed it is
there any uh i hate them
you hate them does anyone agree with uh
anything to see any truth in what they
did
now it's messed up
i don't know it like it depends on if it
really was like disruptive to the
environment to go out there and install
that thing like did they like
have to like drill into the ground or
anything sure
probably i don't know i mean obviously
it's kind of a douche move but i don't
understand why somebody would be annoyed
by it let me just tear down every
building we've ever built yeah
right well just tear down just [ __ ]
wipe just
let's just let's just push all of los
angeles into the sea
for disrupting the environment but this
this was theoretically in some sort of
nature
preserve or something right i don't know
it's just in a desert
i think it is i think it's in a big
national park
but it's been there for four years
that's a thing like or even possibly
longer
yeah i mean i feel like they should have
just got more of an explanation or
been more transparent about why they
were moving if they did
it seems like their intention was what
we think pretty clearly and they're just
like [ __ ] this trash
in the desert could they have been the
ones that installed it though
now i don't think so i think the
implication is very
well i think at first people thought it
was but now very clearly i think they're
just as dan says
banners
dan
well what about what about launching
[ __ ] in the space should we bring all
that and
incinerate it it's natural habitat i
guess the void of space
you know i'm saying where does it where
do you say like
like we have to throw away this
thing and because it's in this nature
reserve or
i don't even know if it's a nature
reserve frankly i think there's no
i haven't seen that written anywhere
but like you know what's not in nature
spaces of nature why can't we blast it
into space now we're pulling all the
[ __ ] satellites back in
come on but also at this point it's
already been done it's already there
and now it's everyone's property
to learn what's the history who's the
artist
how long it's been there who is this guy
to come in and call it trash and just
what did he do with it exactly where did
it go they stole it and it's not theirs
also they're not like park rangers you
know what you mean it's not like they're
sanctioned by the by the municipalities
yeah you know you know what the actual
municipality are the ones that
discovered it and they [ __ ] left it
there
and videoed it and put it out because
they thought it was cool
the actual it was the utah department of
public safety are the ones that
discovered it
so if anyone should remove it it's them
and they left it there
true thank you i rest my case
the space thing though is interesting
that actually is have you
heard about this whole thing about space
debris and orbit and how it's
yeah potentially getting really bad and
we can't uh we might not be able to fly
to space eventually if we don't do
something about it
yeah we're gonna have to take care of
that space to be yeah first trail
yeah but monoliths aren't debris come on
it's just because on the space station
they just throw all their junk out into
space
well i think old satellites or or
accidents that happen up in space
they'll figure it out
they'll get like a big ass in the head
up there and start catching [ __ ] they
will they'll figure it out get some
lasers or something
shoot that [ __ ] yeah vaporize it space
vacuum
you see elon making a laser they'll
figure it out
once it becomes a real problem okay
i've got a great segment here
great great segment should we talk about
bell just so we can put her in the
thumbnail the bell definitely selling
our condom
thoughts prayers let's do it what's the
story
so delphine you know she's announced
she's doing porn
well you should be happy and excited to
know
that she will be selling the condom used
in her first porn it's disgusting
no will she really be selling the condom
i think she why wouldn't she
she will be selling it apparently right
here she'll oh
maybe she says it on this podcast so
thick feels very strange
is this the first time you've put this
publicly yep it's been
completely you full screen you know
under the radar i just kind of felt like
i wanted to
end the year kind of crazy hang on you
revealed that on our show
the part the yeah yeah excuse me
what even is happy hour on my twitter
saying i'm trying to i'm just all mad
because he's doing another podcast
i get here turn the music down born on
christmas day on my only fans
and i pulled my top up and i showed my
titties you can't even say it now
all right i'm out so zach are you going
to be in the bidding for the condom
should we bid
as a collective show for the condom what
would we do with that
i think that make a great bit but i mean
in reality it's some dude's jizz
yeah i don't get that i caught them do
you think it's going to come without
some guys i what okay what if she uses
it
and then they wash it off but it's like
why would you watch it because it's
it's just the historic nature of it it's
not for the bodily
fluids we gotta frame it you know
i don't i'm not sure how i feel about
having a used condom frames on mine
[Laughter]
i wonder what it's going to go for
though like you know
i mean it's a piece of history
but who would want that
you you underestimate
well let's take some wagers here what do
we think it's going to sell for because
i'm quite curious
a thousand bucks i mean maybe probably
more than a thousand
i stay 10 grand really
i wouldn't [ __ ] pay that no maybe i
pay 100 bucks for it for a gag and then
throw it out probably
yeah would you use it would you use it
like use it again just to connect with
her zach because i know you're a fan
i mean maybe jerk off with it or
something but
again again it's like some dude's like
load
no no you wash it you don't jerk with
this load bro
but then it gets a condom yeah then it
gets rid of like her juice and like now
that it's just the condom
okay let me ask you this hold on
disgusting i can't believe you said
juice i didn't say he said no zach
i can't believe he said maybe yeah yeah
he's open to it wait we're gonna go back
yeah so so let me ask you this zach
if she put it on like a dildo and used
it in that fashion would you
buy it and then jerk off with it to
connect with her i mean that's a
different story but that's a yes from
you
no i mean
yeah why not i mean if the price is
right why not if the price is right
exactly yeah
yeah i mean it's a piece of history
maybe she'll send it to us just for that
purpose because like she's a fan of the
show
and i feel like if j if zack jerks off
with it then
then it really elevates the piece it's
great content you know i mean
it's a piece of history dan how are you
feeling about this conversation
discussing yeah
yeah well it is what it is dan
what if there's a dude's jizz no no go
no
no that's a different story what if i
paid you to jerk off with a dude's jizz
condom
if you paid me i just stepped in the
boundaries
i mean everyone has their price right
right right right of course
a b do you have a price uh not for this
one
you [ __ ] me not for a million bucks you
wouldn't do it for a million dollars
yeah you would i would do it for a
million bucks i'd jerk off with a
[ __ ] used condom
a million bucks man he was like no you
wouldn't
okay how about a billion ela
a billion dollars no damn
a billion dollars over there just lost a
billion dollars because yeah
all right i have this one last segment i
want to talk about which is so
great um and so basically we
we compiled all these right wing
pastures who are all
you know maggot out and covet deniers
i don't know what's the common
denominator between all these like
teletella evangelists
and kovid deny they're all mega and
they're all
kova denying it's just it's so odd
so it's all really good um let's start
here
yeehaw i saw this picture
of the people in the ballots they are
all and what my eye was drawn to was
the tables
the tables this is when they were doing
a recount of the votes
and what the lord started to talk to me
about was
he went through and he over turned
the tables what are on those tables
ballots balance dude don't you
understand the god you're painting is
such a pathetic
weakling he if he willed it then he
would have won he wouldn't need to go in
there and interfere with the recount
he would have [ __ ] won from the first
place yeah he's kind of a loser
it's like the god you're painting is
such a weak [ __ ] like dude
you really think your god is so great
he's got to go [ __ ] with a recount
if god was so if your god was so
infallible it would have won
resounding the [ __ ] first time
he was busy talking to this guy what are
we going to do what are we going to do
don't these guys see the ultimate irony
of painting their god as this weak
pathetic guy who has to go [ __ ] with
recounts because his [ __ ] asking dude
the first time
i could see was he was walking up and
down
those aisles and he started turning over
the tables the tables are being turned
over god is like
those tables are being turned over the
tables are blind
and he came to a table
[Applause]
[Music]
this is really your god
glory glory i love it
this guy's tripping dude somebody's
talking to him about
turning tables that's what i'm saying
like
how great is that god he's like a
belligerent drunk who's just stumbling
around
flipping tables because he's mad his pr
his guy lost it's like dude you're got
it's all on you bro you know
there's so many of these and they're all
great here's another one
rna the vaccine they're coming on is an
rna
vaccine that actually changes your dna
so it's they want to remove the gut
factor out of people that they won't
feel god they won't be because a lot of
the stuff was
developed by darpa really in
the creation of the super soldier which
they wanted to bring about
soldiers that had no emotions whatsoever
so a lot of the stuff
it's all the end time wicked plan of the
enemy
to totally destroy you
the vaccine they're coming on so this
guy's theory
he's a right-wing pastor an ardent
conspiracy theorist says that the covid
vaccine is a satanic plot to change your
dna
okay and remove the god factor out of
people
so i didn't know that was uh i didn't
know that was in the dna
yeah that's in the dna it's not in my
dna he's talking about like darpa and uh
creating super soldiers and [ __ ]
yeah sounds like a that's pretty hype i
mean like space marines or yeah captain
america it sounds like he's been
watching someone's captain america
man i can't believe people actually
listen they don't even make sense he's
doing like a word salad
people sound cuckoo
damn it god invented covets
i imagine like a session of this guy
talking to a therapist
that's what it looked like it's like
okay so so go back to the voices you
have in your head
so god told you what he was in there
flipping tables
okay what do the tables mean hold on the
tables represent the balance
so did you actually flip any table or
no god flipped the table damn it so
you're having visions
[Applause]
uh here's the next one is george pearson
declares that people have died and gone
to heaven
are crying about the alleged voter fraud
that stole the election
sounds about right oh it's the same guy
this is the flip
table guy we love flip the table guys
not right
this is not right
all the way there ain't nothing more
christ-like than a man that [ __ ] a porn
star while his wife's married and pays
her off to not talk about it
yeah he's our god
that's a man that lord sent us yeah
ain't nothing more christ-like than a
man that owns miss america page and
intentionally walks in on young girls
changing
that's what i'm talking about
a line even to
people who have died and gone to heaven
amen hmm think about that now the image
that you've seen of a guy with a
clipboard in a cemetery
say what writing down names say the [ __ ]
what
especially if those people were born
again they're in heaven right now
amen the therapist is like so who's
right and they're crying
is that you at the cemetery against the
injustice
amen
you cannot come against
the lord of the saboth
the lord of angel armies
angels angels on your body bro
they are out there remember the last
time we did this
what are we going to do these guys took
the angels from africa and asia
and brought them to america they're
important
angels [ __ ] all your angels are belong
to us
that is one victory victory voice is
crying out
it is not just the people it it is the
ballot
itself he's still going on about the
ballot dude come on
you [ __ ] lost bro is this a real this
is just a political rally like how is
this
how is this church this is why i have a
problem with these guys they don't pay
taxes yeah religious exception but all
they talk about is politics
tax this [ __ ] guy if you're going to
be talking about ballots and donald
trump and mega
you're paying taxes [ __ ] what
happened to separation of church and
state it seems like it only goes state
to church but never church to stay
it goes both ways you [ __ ] hack
also you're mandatory to see a therapist
yeah who was flipping the tables
god was very interesting
why again
now god now don't you think if it was
god's will for donald trump to win he
wouldn't have to go to redo the voucher
no no okay
it's all god's plan
and let's see we got so many
robert henderson said that kamala harris
is driven by the
an antichrist spirit holy [ __ ]
oh yeah let's go [ __ ]
yeehaw it says the kings the rulers
the politicians they want
to do one thing that are that are driven
by this antichrist spirit they want to
the bible says they want to break the
antichrist spirit
wants to give health care to poor
americans
[Applause]
we gotta kill the devil the antichrist
spirit wants to tax
billionaires not in america folks
not in america yeah
katherine the bodies of the lord in
pieces and cast away their course
in other words they want to become freed
from the influence of who god is
it says it clearly in songs too oh so
this
is what is happening in our nation today
this is listen we have a we have a
vice president-elect that wants to
legalize
prostitution you tell me you never
[ __ ] a prostitute
i guarantee that god [ __ ] a prostitute
and that's just one little bitty piece i
mean you know
that is against god and his standards
the knowledge of god the antichrist
antichrist spirit it's funny a lot of
really christian
countries in europe have legal
prostitution so i don't know get your
[ __ ] straight
god cannot get his [ __ ] [ __ ] straight
just you know what i mean
all things are possible exactly so like
why even try to control it
in march right-wing pastor and radio
host e w jackson boldly declared
that he'd never get covered 19 because
he was protected by god
spoiler alert ela he got covered 19.
here he is see folks i'll tell you
something i'm going to boldly say this
i will not get the coronavirus
i will not get it who do you think you
are how can you say that
because i've asked god to protect me
from ye hi and i've confessed psalm 91
over my life and over the life of my
congregation and over the life of our
families
and we're not getting it in the name of
jesus
in the name of jesus in the name of
jesus i will not get covet free victory
watch this man be with you today it's
good to see all of you on
facebook live um i want to say that i've
been out for the last several weeks
a couple weeks i was out because i was
speaking somewhere else
go ahead and the last one comes out
because go ahead i was tested positive
shouldn't you just quit no you
you [ __ ] now he's gonna tell himself
that god is testing me god is testing me
yeah
yeah whenever [ __ ] is free victory it's
a test
there's always an excuse you after that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you pack up and you never preach again
in fact you're actually just
dropped christianity all together
because god if there's a god he
literally was like
[ __ ] you dude
i was sick with covid for two weeks and
i almost died
but i'm back to you on facebook live
here to tell you that
i will definitely not get covet twice by
god's providence
vote donald trump and recount those
ballots damn it yeah
[Applause]
do that safely and um i'm just grateful
to god that my wife is
uh of course she got it from me
oh yeah god didn't protect her now buddy
and uh she's gonna be back to work
tomorrow okay
[Music]
we gotta get rid of california free
victory we gotta get rid of those
coastal elites
they giving us way too much money now
boy
and finally we have pastor terry pearson
daughter of kenneth copeland oh good
family
says god is up in heaven laughing at the
wickedness of those who mocked her
father
yeah either your time is up but we'll go
after this one last one
this is one crazy family eh
[Music]
oh it's the same [ __ ] guy it's the
ballad guy huh
there are a lot of people made fun of
brother copeland for laughing in the
spirit
bless the lord oh they're taking youtube
videos right now
we are taking youtube videos
they're mad apparently that we goofed on
them they're mad
that's like the meme of like the smiling
face under the crying face
i hope you're taking that youtube video
right now
me laughing
you think this election is over
[ __ ] well eela you gotta go
yes i have to go how long we've been
going
uh for like an hour yeah we can just
wrap it up
[ __ ] it but i do have to go yeah okay
all right elo should i say anything no
the show's over we'll just end it
this is it this is this is then this is
we're done we're here
yeah we've reached should i not say i
have to go you want to just do an ending
you could say you say whatever you want
we're done
this is the end of the show just do a
regular ending bye guys this is the
regular
bye everybody have a great uh week we'll
see you on
friday although we're shooting an
episode on thursday that's coming up
monday with contra points
right right right right
but i'm hoping to get back into a four
per week coming up soon
next week we're trying to figure out um
we got holidays coming up
yeah we're going to show you a lot going
on but uh
see you next week guys or on friday i
[Music]
mean
you